zone Europe sur
[Musique]
sensation
holà bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de zone Europe sur Radio
sensation et tv78 une émission spéciale
enregistrée à Barcelone en Espagne
l'Espagne un pays de plus de 47 millions
d'habitants membres de l'Union
européenne depuis le 1emier janvier 1986
et membre de la zone euro depuis le 1er
janvier
1999 zone
Europe l'Espagne est la première
destination des jeunes Européens qui
partent étudier dans le cadre du
programme Erasmus plus rencontre à
Barcelone je m'appelle rikel Eric
andriana je suis en 3e année de double
licence en philosophie et en sciences
politique donc 20 ans et ça fait
maintenant 3 ans que j'étudie à Paris
pour cette dernière année je je suis
dans le cadre d'un échange universitaire
en Erasmus à
[Musique]
Barcelone pour ma part ça a été
principalement pour la langue pour la
langue espagnole j'avais le champ entre
l'Amérique latine ou un autre donc voilà
un autre pays hispanophone l'Espagne et
mon choix c'est porté sur l'Espagne
parce que je voulais garder cette
dimension européenne même si je n'ai pas
eu le cadre d'approfondir énormément les
questions européennes c'est quand même
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
m'intéresse on va dire un peu plus et
sur lequel j'ai une vision j'ai
peut-être un rapport un peu plus proche
que l'Amérique latine et pourquoi
Barcelone parce que la question des
identité quand même quelque chose qui
m'intéresse c'est-à-dire que pendant 17
ans j'ai vécu à la Réunion territoire
français mais avec quand même une forte
identité réunionnaise et française et
pour le coup me retrouver dans une
communauté aussi particulière qui est la
communauté catalane Barcelone euh je
pense que un peu de tout ça a fait que
je me retrouve actuellement en Espagne
sinon enfin en Espagne surtout à
Barcelone et sinon ça a été aussi
l'occasion et c'est l'occasion pour moi
de découvrir de nouvelles matières des
matières que je n'ai pas l'occasion de
faire dans mon parcours universitaire
donc dans mon parcours je peux faire des
sciences politiques je peux faire de la
philosophie mais c'est vrai que je n'ai
pas forcément le choix d'approfondir
certaines parties par exemple en science
politique je peux approfondir un peu
plus le côté affaires publi actuellement
avec des cours
comme analyse des politiques publiques
finances publiques donc des choses que
je n'ai pas forcément eu l'occasion de
beaucoup travailler
dans mon parcours
[Musique]
principal pour pas mentir et être
transparent je ne vais pas faire une
vidéo YouTube ou avec 46 choses à faire
du matin au soir mais bon généralement
une journée Erasmus on va dire que ça se
passe en deux grandes parties le réveil
qui se passe en général entre 7h30 et
midi donc tout dépend de comment est-ce
que la soirée s'est passée et ensuite
l'après-midi le soir avec les
différentes activités qu'on a en tant
qu'Erasmus on se voit entre amis le soir
on passe du montant voilà ce sont les
deux grandes parties de la journée
ensuite plus précisément en
général le matin de pour ma part je n'ai
pas de cours donc je me concentre un peu
plus sur mes projets personnels je fais
pas mal de candidaturees en ce moment
parce que j'aimerais bien au second
semestre continuer sur d'autres projets
ou sinon dormir tout simplement parce
que l'Erasmus c'est aussi l'occasion de
changer un peu d'air
et l'après-midi je le consacre plus au
cours parce que petite particularité que
je retrouve ici c'est que j'ai eu
l'occasion de choisir vraiment des
plages horaires par exemple je n'ai
quasiment que des cours l'après-midi ici
à Barcelone donc l'après-midi mes cours
et ensuite le soir et bien libre à
chacun de continuer pour ma part c'est
des sorties entre amis du sport aussi
parce que je peux faire du sport et ça
c'est c'est quand même assez agréable
possibilité grâce au SAF qui est le
Service sport à Barcelone à l'UAB notre
université barcelonaise et voilà en
[Musique]
général pour toute personne qui est à
peu près dans la situation que j'ai à
100 % je la recommanderai forcément en
tant qu'étudiant sciences politique
intéressé notamment par les questions
internationales les affaires publiques
mais aussi les questions internationales
la diplomatie à 100 % ce serait une une
recommandation surtout là où je suis à
Barcelone parce que il me semble que
Barcelone n'a pas le je dirais n'a pas
la la la réputation qu'elle mériterait
c'est-à-dire que pour les Français je
trouve que la barrière catalane est
encore un peu trop forte alors que le
catalan est quand même une langue à
l'entrecroisement entre le français
l'italien l'espagnol qui qui peut se
comprendre qui peut se travailler assez
assez rapidement avec un peu d'effort
donc à 100 % je recommanderai cette
destination et sinon les Rasmus en
général oui alors je ne sais pas dans
quelle situation est-ce que ça pourrait
être quelque chose de regrettable bon il
y a toujours des expériences mauvaises
et des expériences malencontreuses qui
se terminent malencontreusement mal mais
pour ma part c'est vraiment l'occasion
de découvrir des nouvelles cultures plus
que l'on pourrait s'y attendre parce que
pour ma part je m'attendais à retrouver
beaucoup d'espagnol surtout euh de de
catalan mais en fait en Erasmus il ne
faut pas oublier que nous sommes Erasmus
étudiants venants de toute l'Europe en
général mais aussi des étudiants en
accords bilatéraux je retrouve pas mal
d'étudiants du Chili certains
d'Argentine du Brésil et aussi bien sûr
de l'Europe donc des Italiens beaucoup
d'Italiens de napolitain par exemple euh
d'Allemands de britannique enfin bref
vraiment une ouverture incroyable sur
toutes les cultures autant européennes
que
extraeuropéennes
zone
Europe on vient de le voir les étudiants
sont nombreux ici en Espagne qu'est-ce
qui les pousse à venir ici quels sont
les atout de l'Espagne écoutez les
réponses de Alfonso gentil Alvarez
auorio c'est le directeur du service
espagnol pour l'internationalisation de
l'éducation Erasmus plus progr de la un
europeun
personuctiv Erasmus plus est le
programme de l'Union européenne destiné
à tous et à tous les secteurs de
l'éducation éducation scolaire formation
professionnelle études supérieur et
formation des adultes les principales
actions du programme visent d'une part à
soutenir la mobilité des étudiants pour
la formation et d'autre part à soutenir
l'innovation et les collaborations pour
l'échange des bonnes pratiques
éducatives les association pour la
coopération le nouveau programme Erasmus
plus pour la période
2021-2027 dispose d'un budget de plus de
26 milliards d'euros soit près du double
des fonds dont été doté le programme
précédent entre 2014 et 2020 cette
nouvelle programmation est aussi
d'avantage inclusive digitale et
écologique elle doit permettre de
soutenir la transformation digitale
l'inclusion la diversité la lutte contre
le changement climatique grâce à Erasmus
plus il sera également possible de
financer les projets de mobilité de
coopérations internationales pour la
formation et pour plus de 100 millions
de personnes de tous âges et de tous
pays l'objectif général du programme est
d'aider à travers l'apprentissage
permanent le développement des projets
d'éducation tant au niveau personnel que
professionnel des personnes évoluant
dans les secteurs de l'éducation la
formation la Jeunesse et du Sport
et ce aussi bien en Europe qu'ailleurs
dans le monde ainsi Rasmus plus
contribue au développement durable à la
création d'emploi de qualité à la
cohésion sociale et encourage aussi
l'innovation à fortifier l'identité de
l'Union européenne et la vie
démocratique grâce à son volet inclusif
Erasmus plus offrira davantage
d'opportunités pour tout le monde y
compris les personnes issues d'origine
de milieux sociaux et économiques
diversifiés les demandes de subvention
sont également simplifiées pour pouvoir
faciliter les candidatures des plus
petites
Erasmus plus est aussi plus numérique
l'aide au développement des capacités
numériques est renforcé en lien avec le
plan d'action dédiée à l'éducation
digitale de la Commission
européenne Erasmus plus est plus
écologique conformément au pacte vert
pour l'Europe de la commission le
programme donnera l'exemple en
encourageant les participants à utiliser
des transports à faible émission carbone
comme le train et le bus en plus de
soutenir les projets qui sensibiliseront
au changement
climatique enfin Erasmus plus sera plus
international permettant ainsi la
coopération avec des pays tiers une
coopération qui était jusqu'à présent
réservé aux études supérieurs et qui
sera désormais étendue aux autres
secteursant les étudiants le personnel
enseignant et nonenseignant pourront
aller à l'étranger pour étudier
travailler
le nouveau programme sera également
développé de manière à soutenir
davantage l'inclusion des personnes qui
en ont le plus besoin personnes en
situation de handicap précaire ou
réfugiés selon le dernier rapport
Erasmus plus de la Commission européenne
l'Espagne reste le premier pays
d'accueil pour les étudiants Erasmus
plus ayant reçu 52830 étudiants en
études supérieur l'Espagne est aussi le
deè pays d'origine des étudiants en
Europe avec plus de 44000 jeunes espol
qui ont pu étudier dans un autre pays
européen concernant les autres publics
c'està-dire l'éducation scolaire la
formation professionnelle et l'éducation
des adultes l'Espagne se situe aussi
dans le haut des classements
européens d'autre part à la fin de
chaque année universitaire nous
organisons le salon étudi en Espagne ce
rendez-vous permet de faire valoir les
avantages de l'Espagne et de son
systèmeivers
qui est une référence internationale
destinée à tous les étudiants qui
souhaitent se former quel que soit leur
niveau d'étude l'Espagne offre une
expérience de formation reconnue moderne
et avancé qui permet aux étudiants de
développer et d'exprimer leurs qualités
dans notre pays un pays européen
inclusif durable digital sû créatif et
qui encourage
l'apprentissage au talent à l'innovation
et à l'inclusion elles sont aussi des
exemples international bien positionnés
dans les classements internationaux les
universités espagnoles dispose de
nombreux programmes en anglais et
bourses d'études ainsi selon le dernier
classement international de Shanghai 12
établissements espagnol ce classe parmi
les 500 meilleurs du monde toutes ces
qualités combinées à notre qualité de
vie notre gastronomie et notre climat
font de l'Espagne la porte vers le
futur zone Europe sur
[Musique]
sensation
j'ai rendez-vous maintenant avec Max
Vasser il est directeur de l'Institut
français ici à Barcelone il a été créé
en 1921 pour favoriser les échanges
entre la France et la
Catalogne max Vasser bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes directeur de l'Institut
français de Barcelone depuis septembre
2019 alors je voudrais tout d'abord
qu'on revienne sur votre parcours avant
d'en savoir un peu plus sur les
activités de l'Institut vous avez
beaucoup voyagé est-ce que vous pouvez
nous raconter un peu vos voyages euh
professionn professionnellement pardon
j'ai j'ai pas tant voyagé que ça euh il
s'avère que la direction de l'Institut
français de Barcelone c'est mon deuxè
poste euh pour le ministère des Affaires
étrangères j'étais auparavant en
Amérique centrale au Salvador où je
dirigeais l'Alliance française de sint
Salvador et j'ai dirigé cet
établissement entre 2015 et 2019 et
auparavant j'étais dans mon
administration d'origine entre
guillemets euh chef d'établissement
scolaire dans l'éducation nationale euh
dans l'Académie de lillele à Lille
exactement c'est une bascule qui s'est
faite naturellement pour vous euh c'est
une bascule qui s'est faite
progressivement ça a été le fruit d'une
réflexion assez longue et puis et puis
aussi au moment où la décision a été
prise ça a pas marché tout de suite
puisque je sais pas si vous savez mais
en fait on postule tous les ans un appel
à candidature de qui est publié par le
ministère des Affaires étrangères pour
pouvoir candidater sur ces sur ces
postes là et ça marche pas
obligatoirement du premier coup donc
j'ai j'ai dû me montrer
persévérant j'avais postulé en 2013 ça a
pas fonctionné en 2014 et je suis fini
par partir en 2015 alors on le disait
hein vous êtes depuis septembre 2019
vous êtes arrivés ici à Barcelone si on
doit résumer vos vos missions ici c'est
faire connaître la culture française la
langue française oui en gros c'est ça la
la mission générique effectivement c'est
établir des ponts linguistique culturel
éducatif universitaire et faire en sorte
que euh sur tous ces axesl et sur toutes
ces thématiques là la France puisse
rayonner en Espagne et et et
particulièrement en Catalogne pour ce
qui me concerne euh notre première
mission c'est effectivement de proposer
aux locaux un apprentissage de de la
langue et on a 2000 élèves qui qui sont
là je rajouterai une petite spécificité
au-delà de ces missions et du cadre
général de ces mission c'est la gestion
de la crise covid évidemment puisque je
suis arrivé quand même 6 mois avant que
tout ça ne ne débute et beaucoup de mon
temps et beaucoup de mon énergie ont été
consacrés à à la gestion de de la crise
sanitaire qu'on qu'on traverse et de de
l'ensemble des répercussions que ça peut
générer pour un établissement tel que le
nôtre justement vous disposez de quels
moyens pour gérer que ce soit la crise
sanitaire que ce soit tous les
événements que que vous
organisez d'abord l'énergie humaine est
un est un carburant très fort on s'est
rendu compte effectivement dans cette
dans cette crise que euh en se serrant
les coudes et en se montrant combatif on
pouvait résoudre un certain nombre de de
de problématiques auxquelles on a été
confronté plus
globalement le modèle administratif le
modèle économique de de d'un
établissement tel que N tel que le nôre
c'est un établissement à autonomie
financière ça veut bien dire ce que ça
veut dire ce qui fait que en gros la
majeur partie de nos de notre budget est
composé de la vente des cours de
français qui sont les nôtres donc on est
aussi soumis aux fluctuations de de nos
publics et vous adressez à qui vous
parlez de public alors le public ce sont
des élèves et donc des des Catalans ou
la communauté internationale vivant en
Barcelone qui souhaite apprendre le
français l'Institut français est une
institution centenaire et donc qui jouit
à ce titre d'un certain prestige la
qualité de notre de notre offre
linguistique est reconnue et on on
bénéficie effectivement d'une bonne
visibilité sur sur Barcelone et sur la
Catalogne alors justement quels sont les
temps forts pour vous depuis que vous
êtes arrivés ici à Barcelone des
événements qui vous ont marqué peut-être
euh il y en a plein euh c'est c'est
c'est c'est difficile de de de tirer un
événement je je dirais que on collabore
avec plusieurs festivals qu'on accueille
ici à Barcelone le festival oui festival
de théâtre en français festival olala de
cinéma francophone euh le festival Fire
qui est un festival de cinéma LGBT qui
se présente en en juin tout ça sont des
moments très fort puisque euh ça génère
un flux de public assez important sur un
plan sur un plan culturel euh beaucoup
de beaucoup de de cinéma
et je si je devais retenir un un
événement je dirais que c'est c'est le
premier quasiment que j'ai vécu ici en
arrivant puisque on a accueilli Nicolas
Mathieu qui venait de remporter le le
concours en en 2019 ou non il a remporté
en 2018 on l'aaccueilli en 2019 et euh
et c'est la première fois de ma vie que
je dînis avec un prix concours et ça m'a
impressionné euh je me suis vraiment
bien attaché à à lire le livre à le
relire même pour pouvoir bien échanger
avec Nicolas pendant le pendant le dîner
à la suite de la présentation et s'avère
que pendant le dîner on n'a pas du tout
parler de son livre mais bon c'était
c'était tout aussi intéressant ça quand
même le coup de le lire ça vait quand
même le coup de le lire exactement et je
l beaucoup de livres depuis que je je
suis ici on recevait hier soir marieia
on recevra dans le courant du mois de de
novembre Yasmin ara la semaine
prochaine et à la fin du mois Boris
culck et et Philippe Claudel donc
beaucoup de beaucoup d'auteurs qui qui
passent par Barcelone et qui nous font
le plaisir de venir jusqu'à nous et vous
parliez du public catalan est-ce qu'il
est réceptif à tout ce qui se passe ici
avec l'Institut français il y a une
longue et grande histoire euh euh
d'amitié ou d'amour ou de voisinage
alors ça dépend il des degrés diverses
entre les Catalans et la France d'abord
à cause de
cette du caractère transfrontalier de
nos géographies respectives et puis euh
il y a une histoire commune je crois il
y a une passion on travaille donc cette
année sur le centenaire de l'Institut
français de Barcelone qui a vu le jour
en 1921 tout comme George brassins a vu
le jour en 1921 et quand on parle de
brassins par exemple ici en Catalogne ça
fait écho ça raisonne immédiatement et
cetera donc il y a effectivement toute
une histoire
euh qui qui comment dire raisonne dans
la tête des Catalans aujourd'hui et puis
l'Institut français a joué un rôle assez
important pendant le franquisme pour
maintenir une certaine forme de liberté
d'expression chez les artistes catalans
et je pense que ça reste aussi dans dans
la mémoire collective pense sa que la la
la France représente quoi pour
eux c'est une
question plutôt culturel plutôt la
langue française la gastronomie
ah je dirais que on a tous nos forces et
on a tous nos nos faiblesses la
gastronomie espagnole est
excellente il y a aujourd'hui énormément
de bons vins aussi en en Catalogne donc
moi je découvre ça euh la littérature je
crois que c'est un un thème qui
qui plaît énormément et le cinéma la
littérature et le cinéma ce sont deux
dimensions artistiques qui attirre
énormément les Catalans et puis je
dirais au-delà de
ça l'université la mobilité la mobilité
étudiante on a AFF faaire ici à
énormément de jeunes qui se destinent à
partir étudier en France soit à travers
de programme Erasmus soit pour des
élèves qui sortent de d'établissement
bachibak qui est donc la la la double
euh le double diplôme baccalauréat et
bachirerato en en Espagne ce qui leur
permet d'aller effectivement étudier en
France et euh et je crois que c'est
euh quelque chose qui effectivement les
attire énormément et puis Paris restera
toujours Paris effectivement là-dessus
on pourra jamais contester ça alors on
parlait des événements tout à l'heure
par le passé vous avez accueilli vous le
disiez un des festivals de théâtre de
cinéma beaucoup d'artistes français dont
vous nous avez cité quelques noms quel
plaisir ces artistes trouvent-il à à
venir ici et être confronté confronté à
un regard étranger un regard espagnol
qui est pas forcément le même que le le
public
français bon ça dépend des artistes je
dirais mais pour le cinéma euh c'est
assez intéressant de de de d'observer
les échanges qui se créent euh entre les
réalisateurs qui viennent présenter leur
films on a reçu Christophe Barbier qui
est venu présenter petit pays issu du
roman de de Gael faille dans le cadre du
Barcelona International Film Festival et
il était assez effaré
de la technicité des questions qui lui
étaient posées c'estd qu'en gros les
gens ne l'ont pas vraiment interrogé sur
le film et sur les intentions qu'il a
voulu donner dans le film mais sur
plutôt sur la manière dont il a réalisé
le film et effectivement c'est pareil
quand on reçoit des écrivains beaucoup
de gens lisent le livre et ensuite
demandent à l'auteur comment il a écrit
comment il a travaillé mais il y a très
peu de questions ou en tout cas moins de
questions sur le fond des choses bon
voilà c'est tout aussi plaisant mais
mais effectivement je crois qu'il y a
une un œil assez technique chez nos amis
Catalans qui effectivement essaent de
comprendre comment comment on fonctionne
plus que de s'attacher sur sur le le le
le propos ou le fond des le fond du
sujet je bon c'est une analyse toute
personnelle mais euh et vous pensez que
le public français est tout aussi
attentif à ce qui se passe en Espagne
niveau niveau artistique
cinématographique peut-être de manière
un peu moins approfondie euh moi je suis
vraiment impressionné par euh par les
Espagnols qui connaissent vraiment
énormément énormément de notre culture
et d'utre patrimoine culturel et
artistique beaucoup d'auteurs beaucoup
de réalisateurs beaucoup d'acteurs
beaucoup de
musiciens en France
euh parfois on s'arrête à
Almodovar penéopecus euh calosapon pour
la littérature et peut-être qu'on va un
peu moins en profondeur je en tout cas
humblement c'est c'est c'est sans doute
ce qui me concernait avant que je
n'arrive en Espagne pour ça
effectivement on pe cononnaître une
chose c'est que l'immersion dans un pays
l'immersion que j'ai la chance de vivre
en Espagne me permet vraiment de d'aller
plus en profondeur dans dans la culture
hispanophone espagnole et catalane par
rapport à celle que j'avais avant
d'arriver ici merci beaucoup max Vasser
de nous avoir reçu ici l'Intitut
français de Barcelone vous êtes je le
rappelle directeur de cet institut pour
en savoir plus le site internet
institutfançais.es zone
[Musique]
Europe
un peu de gastronomie maintenant Mathis
godfroire rencontré pour nous le chef
étoilé romain Fornel il est installé ici
à Barcelone depuis plus de 20 ans
qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé à venir à
Barcelone l' envie de découvrir autre
chose l'envie de me projeter dans
quelque chose qui soit un peu différent
d'un parcours classique de cuisinier qui
reste dans son pays c'est surtout ça qui
m'a fait bouger avez-vous eu des
appréhensions avant de venir ici non 2
ans on a peur de rien donc jamais eu
peur et
puis voilà il suffisait de travailler de
de montrer que Ben qu'on Ava envie de de
de s'installer ici de réussir et de
grandir ici comment avez-vous fait pour
vous faire votre place ici ben je suis
arrivé avec rien surtout je suis arrivé
juste avec l'envie de bien faire et une
petite formation en France je suis
arrivé voilà puis j'ai j'ai commencé à
m'adapter à comprendre ce qui se passait
dans cette ville à comprendre ce
qu'aimaient les gens qui habitent dans
cette ville comprendre ce qu'aimaient
les gens qui venaient visiter cette
ville et à partir de là voilà on a
commencé à monter un restaurant puis
deux puis trois voilà on a monté un
petit groupe de restaurant qui s'appelle
gr rouge déjà il faut s'asseoir regarder
observer et et puis s'adapter voilà on
narrive pas avec ni des préjugés on
essaie de voir ce qui plaît et à partir
du moment où on comprend un petit peu ce
qui se passe ici on va voir les marchés
on va voir les gens qui mangent au
restaurant on va voir les restaurant euh
les habitudes et petit à petit on
s'adapte mais je pense que ça ça ça vaut
pour tous les pays du monde votre
cuisine est-elle essentiellement
espagnole ou française bien sûr on a une
touche française mais c'est pas c'est on
a les techniques actuel on a des puis
surtout on travaille on travaille
beaucoup de plats beaucoup de par
exemple ici à la plage on fait des PaaS
par exemple voilà où on fait des
poissons à la braise voilà donc on a
adapté notre notre cuisine à à un lieu
qu'est-ce que vous aimez
ici Barcelone c'est une ville qui est
fabuleuse elle est elle est au bord de
la mer c'est une énergie folle toute
l'année
c'est c'est les vacances toute l'année
quoi non non y a une certaine douceur de
vivre qui est dû à la Méditerranée à mon
avis qui est dû à cette cette envie de
d'avancer cette envie de réussir cette
envie de
de de faire la fête de s'amuser de
construire de travailler qui est
beaucoup plus agréable que dans d'autres
pays zone Europe sur
sensation merci au équipe technique de
radio sensation pour toutes ces belles
images à Barcelone vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission en podcast audio et vidéo
sur notre site et notre application
radio sensation mais aussi sur tv78 très
bonne soirée à toutes et à tous à la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
zone Europe sur
sensation zone Europe avec le soutien
financier de la Région
Île-de-France